نحن هنا في مخيم منقله للنازحين هذا
المخيم يضم اكثر من 40 الف نازح جرام موجه
السيول والفيضانات التي اجتاحت جنوب
السودان هذا المخيم يعاني من العديد من
المشكلات بدءا بجانب التعليمي نحن هنا في
احدى المدارس في هذا المخيم هذه المدرسه
كما نشاهد هنا الطلاب يجلسون ولكن غياب
المعلمين عن هذه المدرسه يشكل واحد واحده
من المشكلات التي تعاني منها هذه المخيمات
الكثير من السكان هنا يشكون من ضعف
الخدمات التعليميه ايضا ضعف الخدمات
الصحيه حيث يشكو الناس هنا من غياب الجانب
الصحي وكذلك ايضا ازمه الغذاء التي يعاني
منها هذا المخيم من المزيد حول هذا
الموضوع ينضم الينا مدير المخيم المكلف
السيده لويس جراند حدثنا عن مشكلات هذا
المخيم
المخيم ده بيعني من الماكلات من شهر 8 ما
في اكل لا احد
برضو يعني
مدارس عندنا الطلبه زي ما انتم شفتوا ما
في اساتذه
كلمه المسجات من شهر ثمانيه
الاخير لزراعه قاعدين نحوله نزرع في سنه
لكن المواد الزراعيه وكل الحاجات ما مهتمه
نعم هذه بعض المشكلات وهذا المخيم يضم
النازحين من اربعه ولايات في جنوب السودان
هي الولايات التي تاثرت بموجه السيوله
والفيضانات يا ولاد اعالي النيل وجنقله
وولايه البحيرات او ولايه الوحده هذه
الامر ايضا يتفاقم الان مع دخول موسم
الامطار الذي ينذر بمزيد من المتاعب
والكوارث لهذا المخيم النازحين هنا